[Music]
Beyonce's mom Tina and her husband
Richard Lawson gave et an exclusive tour
of the Waco theater in Los Angeles ahead
of its grand opening we look at those
twins and we look at blue we look at the
world they're coming in man we call
along work to do the theater gives young
people skills to succeed Tina also
dished on Beyonce's newborn twins roomie
and sir how are they doing they're doing
great they are absolutely beautiful and
there's so much fun I mean I haven't
ever been around twins but I mean it's
so cute I can hardly take it you'll see
the different person oh yeah and I can
only imagine how good blue is as a she's
such a good big sister she yes making
her grow up
then maybe it's bringing some maturity I
mean listen she's only five so how
mature but right but you could see the
transition in terms of her being a
little bit more calm she's the diva but
she's sharing her diva them she might
get some of that diva dum from Grandma
we are obsessed with Tina's Instagram
[Music]
and after my kids got grown and you know
when I'm reconnecting with Richards he
was like Tina why are you hiding all the
time like you know it's time for you to
live your own life and it's true because
you know if my kids had their way I
wouldn't be on Instagram I wouldn't be
any social hate it oh they hate it what
they're just afraid that from 60 times
the time she will do that thing that got
put in the mouth thing yeah and
completely embarrassing and she'll step
out and then you'll get that phone call
mom really you know what somebody but
you know you are live walking down the
street like huh I don't even know how to
do that so you know I make mistakes but
I'm just real about it I'm like that's
what 60 year old moms do I mean they
make mistakes on social media so
everybody can relate to that
so like my mom does the same thing
people love it yeah they give me a pass
[Music]